[Arabic recitation]
[Silence]
Allah subhana wa tala.
was
[Silence]
My dear brothers, respected
elders, beloved youth, mothers and
sisters, we thank Allahhana tala for
keeping us alive one more day on the
path of Islam on the and allowing me and
you to enter his house and worship him
in the manner that pleases
I ask Allahh to accept from me and
except from you that little do his path.
Amen. And I bear witness there's no
deity worthy of worship except for Allah
subhana tala and prophet Muhammad
sallallah.aii wasallam is his last and
final messenger for surely who Allah
subhanaa tala chooses to guide and
misguide choose to misguide can guide
him back the path and we seek refuge in
Allah from darkness of ourselves and
evil of our deeds for Allah is knowing
and all seeing what his creation
does. In the previous weeks leading up
to today, we've been talking about
structuring our inner self, the
ns, the nfs that makes us to be astray
and also the same nfs that if it
becomes grounded with Allah subhana wa
ta'ala, it can reach you, it can take
you to a lever of high piety and become
one of the closest people to Allah
[Arabic recitation]
tala and as such we'll embark on aba
today that I'm hoping I'm saying hoping
that I conclude in two subsequentbas
which I know I will not be able to but
at least we will start on it and
inshallah what Allah desires and wills
will happen and we go from there on
in one of the methods to reign in our
nefs this nef that wants to
go and be the aggressor this nef that
wants to lead us astray is to connect
with Allah subhana wa ta'ala and one of
the easiest ways Allah subhana t has
told us to connect with him is the five
times a day and that's why you see the
salas the five prayers in the day are
staggered in different places if Allah
subhana t wanted to either he could have
had all of them at the beginning of the
day or the end of the day. And it would
have been easier for us to come to the
masjid at one designated time and pray
all of them together and
leave and perhaps probably would have
been a bigger gathering of brothers in
the in the in the messengers. But Allahh
chose for us to have them staggered
throughout the day. so we can come back
and connect with him and humble
ourselves. There is not a greater way
for a human being to be humbled except
when he puts his face in the ground.
And as most
Muslims would attest to
this, we have prayed salah in
places that have not one of those
ordinary places to
pray, right? We prayed in parking lots.
We have prayed on side of the roads. We
have prayed in rest areas. We have
prayed with a musah that was not big
enough to even cover our
foreheads. And I often mention this
story and I'm not mentioning the story
because I want you to think I'm a great
person or not, but I'm mentioning the
story because we appreciate what Allah
has blessed us Muslims with in this
country in the present day. The amount
of massagits and musas that are existing
now, it did not exist when I was in high
school. At least growing up in New York
City, there was not a lot of massagits
around. It might be surprising to you.
The area I lived in that had nothing.
And the only masid that we would go to
was a train ride and it took two at
least trains to exchange. And we would
go to Manhattan on the 96th Street, 95th
street as a big masid. The Saudis paid
for it to be built. It's a huge masid.
Mashallah. If you ever get a chance to
go to visit New York City, look at it.
It takes up an entire block in the city
and it's a beautiful
masjid. But when it came time for salah,
there would be no places for us to pray.
So for those who are known or know the
New York City, there's a famous bridge
called the tribal bridge which connects
the three bors. I've prayed salah
underneath it in rain in cold without a
mus on a bare on the bare pavement. So
this is the blessing of Allah subhana
tala. A man who's walking around and if
a little speck of dirt gets on his on
his clothes and he's what is this?
And the same man when he comes to a
house of Allah or he's has to pray to
Allahhaala sometimes he has his clothes
on the floors in the
dirt. You get ready to go a big event
and mashallah you're there you're
attending that everybody's dressed up
nicely looking and then it's time for
you to pray salah. And where do you go
pray
salah? on the floor.
So that's the best way that Allah
subhana t has kept it us for us to be
conscience and be in
humility that salah that connects us
with Allah subhana wa
ta'ala and what is the essence of salah
itself the essence of salah itself
is and this is not me saying this is
Allah subhanaa tala says the hadith
mentioned in authentic narrations we
will not be covering this hadith today
but I'll just mention it so we can
establish why am I saying this saying
this statement the essence of salah is
the fat itself and nothing
else
asam
says I have divided the salah between me
and
in two
halves. Okay. And then the hadith
continues. Okay. So Allah is saying
salah is the fat
itself. It is the essence. And
unfortunately today our condition has
become as such. And with all due respect
with all due respect to the mash and the
and and the and the I say this with the
most humble statement. We prepare for
salah to focus on the surah that comes
after the fata and we forget the
fata which Allah subhana t is saying a
salah is fat and fata is the salah.
instances that you went through so fast
that you don't even remember you read
fat or you did not read
fata you you these these things do
happen people ask questions about
it and for just a statement
wise if you just read fat in salah your
salah is valid completely if you did not
read anything after it we're not saying
you should not read anything after it in
the first two raqas but if that's all
you
knew because let's point to the hadith
ofam and this is a major hadith and by
the way I had a I had a when I mentioned
this hadith long time ago at a different
masid I used to I used to serve one
of the brothers had a huge problem with
me he said how dare you say this I said
this is not my words
ofam the hadith is explicit
Whoever does not read the fat of the
book is not one of us. Is not amongst
us. Meaning
what? What does it
mean? It means the person is no longer
in the fold of Islam. Am I correct? Am I
wrong? The hadith subsequent is what? As
I mentioned last week in the after the
haditham said a person if you see a
person come to the masid give testimony
that he's a
Muslim but this is
saying who has not read the fat from the
book is not one of
us and and in true sense when you say it
also means memorizing it. It doesn't
mean just to read it in that sense.
Doesn't mean just to read verbatim
what's written in front of you. It also
means
memorizing fat is one of the greatest
suras in the
book and
forb have a differentiation either it's
or for it's been revealed twice. It came
in Mecca and it came in Medina too. For
some distinction is that it was revealed
in Mecca. But for some they say no it
was revealed twice in Mecca and
Medina regardless the fact you know it's
it's an opinion I I to mention
different opinions when I do when I do
at times.
So it's a it's a it's a it's a surah
that is
amazing has mentioned over 24 names for
this for the fat. And of course I'm not
going to mention 24 names for you. We're
going to focus on the main names that
are mentioned fat by itself which is
mentioned in the Quran what is in
fat the word root itself means two
different meanings means two meanings.
One is to open it
up you know it's one meaning and the
other it comes
from to be victorious.
And the fat comes from a time when you
are stuck in a spot or a position
there's no way out
from. Meaning what this fat will take
you out of every single issue and the
calamity you have in your
life. And the next two are very close to
each other. They have the same root so
to speak
as now for people if you're Arab or not
Arab doesn't matter to you know you know
the word what
means but
itself in a meaning it does not really
mean the mother it means the
ess is your origination point where do
you come from as a human being your mom
is your original original point. She is
the one who's conceived you. So that's
your
so meaning that's the essence or the
actual of the Quran
itself. And look at it amazingly by the
way it's seven verses and for some there
is a distinction. What ayah is continued
for
some is part of the first verse? It's
included in the first verse of the
Quran. For some, so they divide, you
know, they they do it and the last two
verses are joined together. For some,
they have made a distinction and said,
"No is not part of the fata. We read it
separately." And then, you know, you
have the seven ayats afterwards.
regardless of the
fact is still seven verses.
Now let's go to the the the the name
that Allah has mentioned in the Quran in
the have mentioned it and they there's
an on this
is as we
read in 87
ayah Allahh
[Arabic recitation]
wasallam
We have given you the most recited seven
verses and the
Quran. Meaning what that seven verses of
al fat the rest of the 113 chapters in
the Quran are literally the ex Jesus of
those seven verses.
So you tell me now what's more important
in the
salah. And yet we have no
idea what a great surah it is that we're
reciting in al
fat. I mean think about it this way. If
you have four rakas of salah after this
after in the third rakah you don't read
in the first salah by the way I'm not
saying you know first salah and you know
you do not read anything after the fat
why because the essence of the salah is
that surah
itself and we are so oblivious to the
fact by the way if you sit with Quran
teachers I'm talking about teachers who
are really good good and great teachers
They either will ask you to start with
fata or they will finish on fata.
So if you're reading the Quran, they
will tell you start with fat. And you
will say, "No, no, she we're reading
Bakar." He says, "Okay, I understand.
Read fat first." And he will ask you to
read fat. And then he will say, "Okay,
let's pick up from what's and bakar
we're at." And for some teachers, I've
noticed they will do the regular reading
and they will
end now. Let me hear fatha from you now.
And by the way, one of the names for the
fat that I personally is a shaf as
well because it's used for
shif for some scholars it's part of the
as well. You can use it as on yourself
or somebody who's sick. And by the way,
but you know is not just for the or the
or evil something. It could be for as
well as basically healing yourself by
the will of Allah subhana
tala and the the way you do it from fat
it's recommended seven times and you
know you do on yourself or or the person
who is sick inshallah and Allahh
provides them cure there's a detailed
hadith and we can mention it tonight
after the prayer of how it came to be
and what the the sahaba did in time of
suham
But
understanding the three of the greatest
names of Allah are mentioned in that
there's actually four total mentioned in
this in this but the three are if you
have those three you can
subsequently basically just define every
single thing Allah subhana
t's are is Allah
and those are the three greatest names
of Allah subhana tala and for some
scholars the essence of all the rest of
the names comes from these three major
names and we have
aasoolah that subsequently points in
that direction as well by the way you
have to understand
sometimes did not make it super clear
but we have it where there is the
narrations ofatam where he's mentioned
that we should ask Allah subhana tala by
his and the direction indication is to
Allah that's
the and of course it goes through
alhamdulill and for some recitation we
have some we have either one is correct
you know if you're reading from
different narrations and authorities
but stick to one inshallah. But the idea
was to start a conversation today about
this so that inshallah look there is
every single day each one of us if we're
praying our five salas
inshallah we're reading it 17 times bare
minimum I'm not including the sunnah and
everything else I'm talking about salah
17 times every single day you're reading
fat it's on repeat 17 times times and we
assume if the twothirds of the Muslim
population in the world today is reading
five times a day salah fat is being
recited over 7 trillion times a
day and these are just rough numbers
don't come to me and say this 7 trillion
times a day we're reciting al fat as an
we're assuming twothirds of us are
praying every single
day that's an amazing
Remember for an amazing
surah a surah whereas sallallahu alaihi
wasallam held the hand of a
sahhabi and I'm running out of time mah
again. he read the hand of a sahhabi
and he said before you leave the masjid
I will teach you one of the greatest
suras that has ever been
revealed. Immed Ahmed has mentioned in
in his musnet in two two different
variations of the
hadith and
subsequently what it ends on is
thatam advising the
sahabi al fat is the greatest surah of
all. I ask Allah subhana tala to give us
all the wisdom and the insight in his
beautiful Quran. A Quran a book that is
everlasting. A book that is a pure
guidance for
all in this earth and the universe
becauseam was given that book and wasam
was so he's the prophet not only for the
humans on this earth but every single
thing that Allah has created in the
universe he is the prophet he is the
last messenger of Allah and he brought
us
that I ask Allah subhana tala
to enlighten our our chest and our heart
with al
fath and make us from the people who
recited 17 times every day. And make us
amongst the people on the day of who are
enlightened in their faces and in their
with
[Silence]
Alhamdulillah. Alhamdulillah.
Inshallah we'll conclude with the last
look at the fat and if Allah subh gives
us life inshallah we'll be we'll meet
again next Jama and try to dissect and
read some of the ex Jesus on the fata in
detail. if the brothers in the back
or the front can move just a little bit
of front we're kind of getting a little
bottleneck in the back.
Please, brothers, make sure as soon as
you enter, don't don't just take a spot
in the front of the door to pray. It
blocks people behind you and they cannot
walk in front of you
either. Continue to make dua for me.
Inshallah, Allah heal me. I'm still in
pain, still suffering,
but Allah will have his mercy upon
all of us who are
suffering. Allah sallallahu alaihi
wasallam mentioned in in a narration in
an authentic narration that nothing of
this magnitude and I want you to pay
attention to this statement
of nothing of this magnitude for the
surah has ever been revealed in any
other books that were revealed to all
the prophets beforeat wasam.
So nothing has been ever revealed by
Allah subhana wa
ta'ala. And in
the is mentioned that a special door of
the heavens was opened and who have
never come on this earth before brought
down this surah
toatuam. So I I beg you, I will not ask
you. I'll beg you to take the time out
of your time and to sit and read this
surah and learn it in the proper manner
that is meant to be recited and then
take the time and teach your kids in the
proper manner we're supposed to be
reciting. It's only seven verses.
Alhamdulillah, most of us know how to
recite it, but the minor adjustments are
needed from time to time.
Even used to recite the Quran once a
year
on in the month of Ramadan so he can
have his things in order. So it is
nothing below us as human beings to to
spend the time in revision and
understanding the Quran. I ask Allahh to
enrich our lives with this Quran. We ask
Allahh to make the Quran the light in
our graves and the light in the
hereafter.
[Silence]
form. Allah
Can
[Silence]
Foreham
speech.
[Silence]
for Allah.
Allah abar.
Strain your lines. Fill the gaps in
between. May Allah subh mercy upon us.
Allahbar.
Alhamdulillah. with thee.
[Silence]
Amen.
Fore! Foreign! Foreign!
[Silence]
Allah
Fore! Foreign!
Foreign!
Foreign speech. Foreign foreign foreign
speech.
[Silence]
Allah s Allah mana.
Allah Allah.
Allahbar.
[Silence]
Alhamdulillah.
Amen.
Allahbar.
[Silence]
Say
Allah. Allahbar.
[Silence]
Allah alone.
Allah. I love this.
[Silence]
I just need a few minutes of your
precious time inshallah. So if you'll be
kind enough to just give me three more
minutes, I will be very thankful to you.
So as you know, we have a school on the
premises of
MCCT and alhamdulillah we'll be adding
fourth grade to it come this
August. We ask Allahh to give us the
ability and the community ability to
continue to grow it inshallah.
So inshallah they will be having on May
20th there will be an open house at the
new building that's built which is on
the back side from 6:00 to 7:00 p.m.
in the second class grade there will be
an open house where the teachers will be
available the principal will be there
and it gives you time and opportunity to
come and ask questions and discuss
things.
if I I I beg you to really think
about If you have children who are at
the age who can attend school to really
pay attention and utilize the service,
especially if they are going into
kindergarten, you don't have to pay
anything so to speak. We have
scholarships available and you also have
a scholar or voucher program from state
of Arizona that can go towards your kids
education. There's very there's a lot of
avenues and I don't have to tell you
what the climate sight looks today.
But what I can tell you personally, I
have a child who is in that program. And
when he gets in the car in the morning
and he tells me to put the Quran on so
he can
recite and
and wall, it makes you happy. It brings
a different kind of joy inside of
you because they have that instilled and
it comes from the program that's being
there. Now we have a program available
for
newborns. We have a program for
toddlers. We have preschool. We have
prek. Then we have kindergarten. Then we
have first grade, second grade, third
grade, and fourth grade.
And I say to you with all due respect,
it is much better that your kids learn
Quran. The worldly knowledge can be
learned at any time. There's a brother
in this mah right now and I don't want
to point him out and say his name. I was
talking to him over Ramadan and
mashallah he's a hus and I said can you
tell me your story of hs and he said my
parents didn't let me go to a regular
school until I became a hus they held me
back and the brother is mal engineer now
so the worldly gains will come if you
keep Allah prioritized in his book and
wahi once you memorize the Quran
everything becomes easy to memorize it's
just the rule of Allah
Tala. So I beg you and implore you. We
have summer program coming up for Rahma.
Ahmed, brother Ahmed is here. Ahmed, can
you raise your hand or stand up please?
Brother Ahmed is here. I'm here in the
office. We have summer Sunday school
which is transitioning into summer
program. If you can't afford either of
the programs, come and talk to us. We'll
find a way to take care of you. Whatever
way it is, we can take care of you.
Inshallah. So mark your calendars. May
20th open school. U open open day the
new building at 6:00 to from 6:00 to
7:00 p.m. If you are part of our
announcement groups, the WhatsApp has
already been sent out. If you're not
part of our announcement groups, you
want to be added on to it, come see me
afterwards in the mah or in the office.
Inshallah, we'll take care of you. Last
but not least, please slow down on the
road next to the masid, please. It's
becoming a very big liability issue in
the parking lot and in the in on the
outside. And subhan Allah, I'm afraid
one of these days a kid's going to get
hit or something bad is going to happen.
So please help us manage this.